[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir on commence avec cette
période de grand froid un député
desivelin qui alerte sur la situation
des sans-abris oui Mathilde il s'agit de
William martiné député la France
insoumise de la 11e circonscription
depuis de nuit il dort avec d'autres
parlementaires LFI dans la rue à Paris
sous une tente de l'association Droit au
logement le campement est installé à
l'entrée du M métro solfer dans le 7e
arrondissement l'objectif de cette
action qui va durer plusieurs jours
dénoncer le nombre de logements vacants
apporter son soutien au sansabri et
parler de leur problématique en 2022
Mathilde 624 s sans abri sont morts en
France William Martinet revient sur sa
dernière nuit interrogée par Grégory
Canalis passer une nuit sous une tente
c'est forcément difficile surtout avec
les températures actuelle avec la neige
qui est tombée ce matinon évidemment moi
ma situation n'a rien à voir avec celle
d'une personne sans abri voilà je sais
que ça ne durera que quelques jours je
sais que j'ai un bureau bien chauffé qui
m'attend après la nuit que j'ai passé
dehors la pire des choses qui existe
c'est l'invisibilisation les sans-abris
sont chasser des beaux quartiers chasser
des centre-villees ils sont même là avec
les Jeux olympiques de plus en plus
chassés de de la banlieu bref ils vivent
leur misère isolé dans leur coin et nous
ce que voulons nous voulons faire avec
cette démarche c'est bousculer les
consciences c'est mobiliser les gens et
leur dire il n'est pas acceptable que
aujourd'hui dans la 7e puissance
économique du monde on est encore des
gens qui meurent de froid dans la rue
parce que malheureusement c'est ce qui
se passe depuis plusieurs jours on
poursuit ces informations avec une
grosse coupure de courant qui a impacté
les ivelinois oui elle s'est produite la
nuit dernière aux alentours de minuit et
à touché les habitants de Montini
lebretonneux Guy en cours saint
cirelécole Bois d'Arcy et Fontenis
lefleurri sur X ex Twitter plusieurs
personnes ont d'ailleurs signalé cet
incident un incident technique qui n'a
aucun lien avec le froid et la neige
selon enedis il est survenu au poste de
distribution d'électricité publique
situé à guyancour au plus fort de
l'incident 53000 clients ont été privés
d'électricité les équipes d'enedis sont
intervenus toute la nuit le retour à
Laan normal est intervenue vers 4h45 ce
matin ça y est Gabriel les inscriptions
sont ouvertes sur parcours sup et ça
tombe bien car un événement sur
l'orientation arrive pour les ivelinois
oui depuis hier les lycéens apprentis ou
étudiants en réorientation peuvent créer
leur dossier sur la plateforme ils ont
jusqu'au 14 mars pour formuler leur vœux
d'orientation dans l'enseignement
supérieur 23000 formations sont
disponibles sur parcours sup et si
l'orientation vous stresse pas de
panique le salon de l'étudiant en
Yveline et là pour vous aider
rendez-vous samedi de 10h à 18h au
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline sur place vous pourrez découvrir
de nombreuses formations parler avec des
étudiants glaner quelques conseils et
obtenir des informations c'est gratuit
mais vous devez vous inscrire sur le
site l'éudiant.fr un QR code d'accès au
salon vous sera envoyé et pour terminer
Gabriel vous nous emmenez à Versailles
oui au château de Versailles même qui
était vous le voyez sur les images sous
la neige ce jeudi des magnifiques images
dont on ne se lasse jamais mais le plus
intéressant mathil se passer à
l'intérieur près de 200 jeunes
francilien y été réunis pour la finale
école des petits champions de la lecture
ce concours est comp pense l'éloquence
pour se faire les enfants lisent un
extrait de 3 minutes d'un livre de leur
choix devant un jury le but transmettre
l'amour de la lecture il s'agissait là
de la première étape la finale nationale
des petits champions de la lecture et
programmé le 26 juin prochain à la
Comédie Française on suivra ça on
reviendra oui sur ce concours la semaine
prochaine dans le 78 merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
actualité qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news